Die dramatische schmelze in der antarktis geht immer schneller vonstatten wenn das gesamte antarktis
schmelzen würde würde der globale meeresspiegel um unglaubliche 58 meter ansteigen diese warnung kommt jetzt von einem
internationalen forschungsteam ist die antarktis noch zu retten jetzt ein klick zum science fiction gibt es täglich neue science videos
abonniert den kanal gerne herzlich willkommen
Vielen dank für den themenvorschlag aus der messenger community wir da rein kommt erfahrt ihr am ende des filmes
219 milliarden tonnen pro jahr eine
unvorstellbare zahl doch so viel eis hat die antarktis im mittel jedes jahr in den jahren 2012 bis 2017
verloren das ist fast dreimal so viel wie in den jahren davor
auf diese ergebnisse kommt ein internationales
forschungsteam um andy sheppard von der university ließ zitat
land unseren analysen ist es in den letzten zehn jahren zu einer beschleunigung des massen verlust in der antarktis gekommen
demnach tragen die antarktis derzeit zu einem höheren anstieg des meeresspiegels bei als je zuvor in den vergangenen
25 jahren vor allem in der westantarktis
ist der masse verlust am größten aber auch in der ostantarktis sieht es lange nicht mehr so gut aus wie in den jahren bis
2012 denn bis zu diesem zeitpunkt hatte es durch massiven schneefall eine zunahme der eismasse gegeben doch auch das ist
offensichtlich längst geschichte in den fünf jahren von 2012 bis
2017 gab es allein in dieser region an jährlichen verlust von
28 milliarden tonnen eis das alles sind die ergebnisse von insgesamt
44 internationalen organisationen die sich zusammengeschlossen hatten um den eisverlust in der antarktis zu
kalkulieren unterstützt wurden sie dabei auch von esa und nasa
konkret beziehen sich die forscherinnen forscher auf 24 satelliten gestützte eismasse schätzung diese wurden mit verschiedenen messmethoden
analysiert mit der messung der schwerkraft der höhenmessung und der
sogenannten input output methode hierbei werden der zuwachs und der verlust von 1 gegeneinander gerechnet als geht beispielsweise
durch das schmelzen und das kalben der gletscher verloren neues eis kommt hingegen durch schneefall hinzu das ergebnis
das eisschild der antarktis hat seit 1992
insgesamt etwa drei billionen tonnen eis verloren mit dieser menge könnte man ganz deutschland rund acht meter hoch mit wasser bedeckt
eine unvorstellbare menge doch eben nicht nur die reine wassermenge ansicht macht den wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern ziemlich viel sorgen sondern eben auch die geschwindigkeit
40 prozent des verlustes passierten der studie zufolge in den vergangenen fünf jahren
das ist schon eine krasse ansage allerdings es gibt unsicherheiten schließlich werden keine neuen daten
präsentiert sondern die vorherigen studien werden zusammengeführt
beispielsweise schwanken die schneemengen pro jahr enorm auch die höhlen änderung die gemessen worden sind sind gering und
bergen würde gefahr dass auch kleinere messfehler größere auswirkungen haben könnten um zu sehen wie sich das heißt tatsächlich
verändert wären satellitenmission notwendig die sich nahtlos aneinander reihen doch die allgemeinen trends die das forschungsteam
vorstellt sind keinesfalls von der hand zu weisen fest steht also der eisverlust geschieht immer schneller und der hauptsächliche tatort ist die
westantarktis hier brechen eiskappen und schärfe so schnell auseinander wie man es sich bisher in den schlimmsten albträumen nicht
vorgestellt hatte und auch die ostantarktis kann die konsequenzen daraus nicht mehr mit starkem schneefall
ausgleichen bremsen oder gar stoppen schon jetzt hat die antarktis wohl acht millimeter zum anstieg des meeresspiegels
beigetragen ging erst einmal
wenig doch da wird in zukunft noch einiges dazukommen eine weitere aktuelle studie hat sich zeitgleich damit auseinandergesetzt was der
anstieg des meeresspiegels
bedeuten wird in zukunft rechnet das forschungsteam mit einem anstieg von einem bis zwei
zentimetern pro jahr das kann man vergleichen mit der letzten kaltzeit tirol agierten die großen eisschilde in europa und
nordamerika in den kommenden 50 jahren könnte die antarktis im besten fall lediglich sechs zentimeter zum weltweiten anstieg des
meeresspiegels beitrage im worst case könnten es aber auch sie 25 cm seien dazu einer der beteiligten forscher
martin siegert einige der veränderungen mit denen die antarktis konfrontiert ist sind bereits ihre versieben wie der verlust einiger
schelfeis gebiete aber es gibt vieles was wir verhindern oder rückgängig machen können
entscheidungen die im nächsten jahrzehnt getroffen werden bestimmen
welche entwicklung
realisiert wird und noch mal für alle klima skeptiker es geht hier nicht um eines das im wasser schwimmt und zu keiner volumen änderung führt
also keinem anstieg des meeresspiegels es geht um eis das sich auf dem festland der antarktis ist also auf dem
kontinent befindet und dort verdunstet oder über gletscher ins meer gelangt so oder so führt es zur steigerung des
meeresspiegels wir müssen also dringend handeln
und wir handeln hier bei pixum übrigens auch kriegs- und wird werbefrei immer wenn wir entsprechend viele kanal mitglieder gewonnen haben schalten wir die werbung
für einen monatlichen video ab werdet also mitglied hier unter dem video draufklicken oder auf den link in der video beschreibung für einen kleinen beitrag
bekommt er dazu noch einige extras wenn er immer garantiert über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt dann endet mich übrigens bei whatsapp
dann bekommt ihr den link zum video vor allen anderen von mir persönlich
auf euer handy einfach hier draufklicken und darunter geht es weiter dafür auch draufklicken mit klimawandel
bestätigt skeptiker endgültig widerlegt bis dann
bleib dran